alkenes are useful synthetic
intermediates they're double bonds can
undergo a variety of chemical
transformations providing useful
functional groups like halides alcohols
and carbonyl compounds let's review some
of the major reactions that alkenes
undergo an alkene can be reacted with
hydrogen gas in the presence of a metal
catalyst to produce alkanes the hydrogen
gas adds to one face of the alkene so we
gets in addition of h2 across the double
bond alkenes react with
halogen-containing acids like
hydrochloric and hydrobromic acid adding
a single halogen across the double bond
if the alkene is reacted with acid in
the presence of water or an alcohol the
result is an alcohol or an ether water
or the alcohol can be used as solvent in
this reaction you may have noticed these
reactions are read yo selectively in our
example the new functional group is
added to the central carbon and not the
terminal carbon of the alkene this is
because these reactions form a carbo
cation intermediate the more substituted
carbocation forms because it is more
stable because carbo cations are
trigonal planar in geometry they can be
attacked by the nucleophile from the top
face or the bottom face so if there is a
stereocenter produced in the reaction it
will be a mixture of r and s when this
happens we say a racemic mixture is
produced the addition of the nucleophile
to the more substituted carbon of the
alkene is sometimes referred to as
markovnikov addition and is related to
carbo cation stability rearrangements
via hydride or alkyl shifts are possible
with these acid promoted reactions
treatment of an alkene with liquid
bromine or chlorine gas adds two atoms
of the halogen across the double bond
and if the reaction is carried out in
water a halo hydron is formed the latter
reaction is
again regioselective and stereoselective
a bromonium ion forms and the
nucleophile attacks at the more
substituted carbon atom because there is
significant contribution of the more
stable carbo cation resonance form here
this accounts for the regioselectivity
the functional groups are also added to
the molecule stereo selectively because
the bromonium ion blocks one face of the
molecule the nucleophile must approach
from the opposite side we call this anti
addition allylic bromination is a
radical reaction that adds a bromine
atom to the carbon adjacent to the
double bond while preserving the alkene
functional group oxy mercury a shin also
forms alcohols from alkenes in a
markovnikov fashion a mercury neum ion
is formed which reacts with water at the
more substituted carbon atom treatment
with sodium borohydride reduces the
mercury removing it from the molecule
the major advantage of this reaction is
that carbo cation rearrangements by
hydride or alkyl shift are not possible
although mercury is a rather toxic
element to use in the lab hydroboration
oxidation forms the less substituted
alcohol phien on markovnikov addition
boron is often substituted with large R
groups to make this reaction more
selective examples of commonly use
reagents are 9 BB n dice I a mole boring
and boring thf the large boron group
adds to the least sterically hindered
side of the alkene while the small
hydride atom is added to the more
substituted carbon atom treatment of the
boron complex with sodium hydroxide and
peroxide in a second stage of the
reaction produces the alcohol the
addition of two hydroxyl groups across
the alkyne is accomplished by treatment
with osmium tetroxide which forms an oz
mate ester this
action gives a sin dial because osmium
approaches from one face one molar
equivalent of a reducing agent is
required to cleave osmium from the
molecule and produce the dial ohsen
alisis essentially splits a double bond
in half creating a carbonyl compound
from each side in our example a
substituted aldehyde and formaldehyde
are formed we need to take a look at the
mechanism to understand what is going on
here the addition of ozone forms amylose
an ID which rearranges to form the ozen
ID in a second step dimethyl sulfate is
added this Cleaves the oxygen oxygen
bond and the charged intermediate
collapses to form carbonyl compounds and
dimethyl sulphoxide the vivek reaction
is an alkene forming reaction that seems
relevant to touch on here a carbonyl
compound is converted into an alkene by
treatment with an organophosphorus
reagent this vinegar II agent is a
phosphorus iLET although we can draw a
resonance structure with a double bond
there's also contribution from a neutral
dipolar form the carbon ion form makes
it a bit more apparent how the carbon
atom of the vit agree agent ends up
bonded to the electrophilic carbonyl
carbon of an aldehyde or ketone the side
product of this reaction is
triphenylphosphine oxide z alkenes are
favored under the classical vitug
conditions when there is a possibility
for resonance stabilization of the
carbon ion the e alkene is more favored
alkene metathesis though a bit more
advanced is an important reaction in
modern synthesis treatment of two
alkenes with molybdenum or ruthenium
catalysts result in the formation of a
new alkene with substitution from the
original alkenes on either side of the
double bond this reaction is most useful
when it is done in an intramolecular
fashion to close a ring